[Music]
as of filming this video about 250,000
of you have watched my recent hour-long
sit-down with Colin Moriarty from Rubin
report YouTube week Colin is best known
as a gaming journalist and as one of the
founders and hosts of kind of funny a
popular gaming talk show I actually
didn't know much about Colin before our
YouTube we chat beyond just a couple
interactions that we had had on Twitter
my intention with the interview was to
get away from politics for a change and
focus on my long-lost love of video
games but within about a minute I could
tell how passionate Colin was about
current events and the political world
sometimes in an interview you expect one
thing but you get something totally
different and in Colin's case this was
the best route that this thing could
have gone right after the interview I
told Colin that he could be a major
conservative political star if you ever
wanted to go that route in life a few
days after our initial interview Colin's
world went completely bonkers Colin
posted a rather benign joke on Twitter
on International Women's Day let's take
a look
ah peace and quiet hashtag a day without
a woman but we got thousands of retweets
and favorites but of course also cause
backlash by the bigoted ears always
looking for something new to be outraged
by by the way the joke itself as Colin
has said isn't the smartest or funniest
thing ever it's actually a really simple
line that every sitcom from I Love Lucy
to Mary with children to Everybody Loves
Raymond has been based on regardless of
whether it was funny or not a firestorm
of outrage began and within a couple
days Colin stepped down from kind of
funny the company he co-owned and the
show he co-created with his friends
regardless of whether the joke was funny
or sexist or just stupid which are all
subjective feelings the point is that
the out of control firestorm was once
again on the attack the online gaming
media jumped all over Colin and in one
case claiming he had gone on a
right-wing talk-show known as the Rubin
report to discuss the tweet of course in
reality we had taped and aired the show
about a week before he even posted the
tweet in the first place the worst case
of this journalistic dishonesty came not
from a gaming
site though but from a mainstream outlet
the International Business Times let's
look at this headline kind of funnies
Colin Moriarty resigns after targeting
women in a racist joke insist it's his
personal decision to say this is beyond
the pale doesn't even begin to describe
it
this social justice warrior disease
combined with a pinch of
intersectionality and a sprinkling of
misguided outrage has a mainstream
publication accusing Colin of racism
where there literally was not a word of
racism in between eventually I was able
to track down an editor of IB Times who
I passed along to Colin and they change
the headline about 24 hours later too
little too late though and the damage
was done just imagine if that had been
you for a moment this is what I mean
when I say that this regressive movement
will come for all of us one day I
suspect that it's coming for private
citizens for wrong thing next we'll just
have to wait and see after all of this
nonsense I get a second interview with
Colin which we live streamed out to you
guys with no editing to clean up the
mess Colin respectfully and honestly
told his side of the story without
throwing his friends and former
co-workers under the bus we also took a
ton of questions from you directly and
shared a really intimate moment of
friendship on camera when the interviews
finished I truly truly felt that we had
done something relevant and important
together we stood up against the outrage
machine against the misguided social
justice movement and more importantly we
stood up for something for ourselves and
if we won't stand for ourselves then why
would anyone else stand for us now this
is where this really gets good last week
Colin launched his own patreon to fund
his new show aptly titled Colin's last
stand as of this taping he has over
thirty thousand dollars a month in
pledges that's more than we have and I
am completely ok with that
I'm beyond thrilled for him as a creator
but more so as a friend it was only
about ten days ago that he had dinner
here at my house and thought that his
career might be over and I've been in
that same boat myself not only did Colin
launch an incredibly successful
Rhian but he's also made some stellar
appearances on glenn beck's radio show
and last week on Joe Rogan's podcast I
mentioned all of this because I view
this whole instance as a massive win for
the free speech anti regressive movement
we can no longer give these hysterical
people an inch because they won't stop
taking until we've all silenced
ourselves obviously many of you see this
and agree with it which is not only why
our interviews did so well but why so
many of you put your money where your
mouth is and join Colin on patreon and
by the way I should welcome our new
patrons as well because we got a bump in
the midst of all this craziness - this
isn't about money though it's about
taking back the narrative from people
who use buzzwords and outrage to silence
the rest of us who are trying to have
meaningful conversations allies are
popping up all over the place in this
space and it's only together that we can
fully fight back the bad ideas which
have led us here
from Colin to Joe Rogan to Phil DeFranco
and many others I see a new alliance
forming of content creators who aren't
political per se but who will no longer
be held hostage by the same outraged
machine that's crushing dissent not
through conversation but by public
shaming we must now destroy the politics
of destruction if we're going to move
forward I think we just got our first
major win and I look forward to you
joining us for many more
[Music]
you
[Music]